hey buddy you that fish boy from the TV
it's fish man
[Music]
do you keeping us Amite usual for as
that could be used me about my vinyasa
to his justice any near my source online
welcome to Hawaii
yeah it's told to come here and pick up
a car under the name Bay wash away okay
under mr. Jason no mister just Jason
sound a little crazy but you're on
Baywatch from ninety nine to ten one
brother basin yes Joseph does that
prepare you at all for being Aquaman in
that realm no no no I mean I think being
a Hawaiian maybe I mean I've been in a
I've been in the ocean you know since I
was a baby and might come from a long
lineage of Waterman so
say cuz the name's Jason and I ain't
hapa anything JC I'm Kai Colburn and how
play is not an insult
it means half or part almost everyone in
Hawaii is haha that's you me uh me one
thing one piece one person all together
[Music]
my name is Carrie Barden in me from Game
of Thrones and it was I was playing a
role Khal Drogo it was a pretty mean
kind of guy and he thought would be
perfect for Conan so I came in I met
Marcus actually in carries office and he
liked he liked what I did
ride ain't over yet man
for a man out there for swimwear for the
summer what would you suggest if you
want to have Aquaman flavor banana
hammocks no mana hammocks no sorry well
that's what Aukerman says jeez just like
a bad I dig it
maybe temporary